c'est il a payé en trop ou en
moins ah d'accord et comment faut-il
faire on descend sur le port d'accord ok
euh je
l'informerai je l'in
ouis oh les gens qui a je te dis pas sac
noir c'est noir de
monde douement douement doucement dou de
voir
ça
pe mais c'est pas
incroable regarde oh tu as vu les gens
en boubou et tout c'est magnifique les
costumes faut que tu passes un peu des
plans là-dedans serré hein ça c'est
sublime tu as vu les tu peux mettre un
tout petit peu de pied à droite s'il te
plaît ou pas Fran à
gauche regarde les costumes des gens
c'est top ici ah là là là là là là les
couleurs sur le marché ou je sais pas
quoi ça c'est top oh là les couleurs des
gens ça c'est pas le marché qu'on a
vu arriv
ça sent le la bouffe tu sais ça sent ça
sent
ici c'est joli ça qu'est-ce tu en penses
superbe
très beau avec le petit marché au milieu
on sent la bouff grillé jusque là ETG
pas vers le bas il y a l' à droite juste
à droite l'ombre on l'ombre doucement
doucement doucement le milieu le milieu
du marché les gens qui regardent en
couleur c'est
magnifique ah c'est super beau ça un J
cadche avec
les
au
mal comm
ça tu la
mettrais qu'il a fini son plan tu
recules tu mets à l'arrière metsom sur
l'eau plus
malour a son
plan couleurs les couleur des gens c'est
top me avec
chap
mettre du pied à gauche ou
pas
VO
stableok bon
écoute
couan